and throw oh i love it awesome we're in
vegas
yahtzee
[Music]
hi i'm alyssa and i'm motoki and this is
expert amateur fraud a show where we try
to figure out who the expert is and
who's faking it today we're going to be
interviewing three
oh
yeah
whoa oh my gosh it's funny i knew that
was actually going to be in there did
you
you're so funny and i knew you were
gonna say that i'm very skeptical though
i will be honest i don't necessarily
believe that there are people who can
just read your mind let's try really
quick think of a fruit and like look me
in the eye when you think of it
i'm thinking about it what is it
pineapple it actually was
that's crazy
i'm looking into everything
i had pineapple this morning so
how did you think i felt it i just felt
it any time i've ever done a tarot
reading they always pull the death card
but they're like that's good death means
a new beginning
i think they just say that because
i'm gonna die
hi lovely to meet you my name is eliza
so my focus is palmistry or chiromancy
otherwise known as palm reading but it
really is so much more than that i
mostly focus on the type that's most
often portrayed in media frankly which
is the indian and romani tradition okay
um so i'd love to do a reading on either
of you yes um i would love it
so
and if you could present your hand to me
like this which one does it matter your
dominant hand tells you what you choose
based on your free will whereas your
non-dominant hand is what our ancestors
have given us ancestors
i kind of have been to what my ancestors
want for me excellent excellent should
we what love i gotta do it like this oh
sorry sorry so romantic love sure yeah
okay um so do you mind if i touch your
hands yeah absolutely
oh so your heart line which is this line
right here i will show you right there
spears off into two different directions
right around your mound of jupiter and
the mound of jupiter is associated with
pride so you have a deep heart line
which shows you feel very intensely but
these two things pride may get in the
way of some of your romantic
relationships that's true
yes and you know pride often stems from
insecurity um
yes and i'd be really curious to see on
your dominant hand let's check it out i
have some wonderful news okay thank you
your heart line is not hugging your
mound of jupiter on your dominant hand
okay so you have um overcome the pride
so it doesn't say anything on there like
who i will marry
again we have free will i can't predict
a specific person i can't say his name
is gonna be josh and he's gonna be a dj
sure but i can tell you you know how you
can impact your own relationships and
what you can look for and what you need
to be aware of let me start with your
non-dominant again because ancestral
warnings um
hmm
yeah so for this i'm paying close
attention to your headline your lifeline
and your mound of mercury because your
mound of mercury dictates how you think
how you process logic how you express
yourself and i'm seeing lots of tiny
markings on that right here here and
here right above a vein
which indicates to me that maybe you're
a bit more spiritual a bit more
passionate than you like to let on you
like to portray this you know
aura of logic reason but maybe deep down
you're a little bit more spiritual and
passionate so do you consider yourself
following any religions at all or
yeah um what got me into spirituality
originally is that my grandmother who
was jewish was very into kabbalah which
is a form of jewish mysticism and when
do you when around was that in your life
so um when i was around 24 i had a bit
of a quarter life crisis as they say
that's me
yes yes and
so i quit my job in reality television
and decided to pursue my own um business
in palmistry you seem like you're
helping people yeah you helped me feel
like
eliza for president
honestly i think a giveaway that someone
is faking their psychic abilities is
when they go into things that are so
overly specific there are fraud psychics
especially mediums who do background
research on people and then go to them
and exploit their grief and their trauma
and try to convince these people that
they're mediums when they're actually
just charging people for
nonsense
so a little bit about me is that i deal
with manifestation in particular
financial abundance your love life and
really just using crystals ruin art and
just realistically journaling in order
to do that sounds good i like all of
this i'm ready to manifest
are you guys on tick tock by any means
i'm going to reference tick tock a lot
yeah
this crystal according to the users of
tick tock they say when it comes to
manifesting it really
is an amplifier when i got moldavite i
broke up with my ex in literally a week
and then after that i moved the second
week and then the third week i booked
like three acting jobs and four modeling
gigs
it was like just so much awesome and you
attribute it to the multiplayer yeah i
did now what would you say to people
that get a crystal
yes and nothing happens so the first
thing that i would say is make sure that
your crystal is charged
what if it's charged so if it is true i
got some crystals and i didn't get any
money
so that's what comes into like the
journals and that comes into the journal
play are you gonna show us your job
yeah oh my gosh stop thinking yeah
everything that is highlighted has been
stuff that i have manifested into my
life while you're writing down your
goals and what you're striving for yeah
how does the crystal play into it so
essentially again it's an amplifier you
want to either hold the crystal in your
hand and actively visualize you're
getting a check from your employer and
it's five thousand dollars but it's
honestly just really using the crystals
and using the energy and tools around
you in order to take you to the next
level of your dream life per se i
personally believe that everybody does
have some innate nature psychic ability
that they can all tap into
and it's to really inspire them that
they too can grow and progress in ways
that they never even imagined they could
do before
howdy howdy hey how are you
dylan so today i thought i would share
with you clara mancy or the art of
throwing bones and tarot when you ask a
question or you ask the spirits you
throw the bones and depending on where
they fall that kind of reveals the
answer
um it's like a og magic eight ball in a
sense essentially yes no are these
actual animal bones yes they are and
they're ethically sourced okay so i'm
gonna start with you okay because i feel
this like
barrier oh wow
that's true he's more
[Applause]
so what would you like to look at oh
gosh be real you can tell me if this is
a good question or not yeah but like am
i on the right path in life yes you can
do a yes and no but there's always a
question behind that yes okay you know
why don't we throw bones in regards to
your path in life okay so yeah
shake shake shake shake shake shake
shake and throw oh i love it wow
good throw we're in vegas awesome
what i want to direct you to is these
rib cages and rib cages what do they do
they protect our organs there's a lot of
protection that i see here while i think
that there is a sense of confidence and
i see you going far i also think that
there's a part of you that is going to
have to strip off that armor and take
more leaps of faith
but also garnet and malachite two stones
also associated with finance and
prosperity
don't make everything about money and
don't make everything about success i
think there needs to be more that you
need to focus on okay interesting yeah
freaking cool yeah let's do a bump ring
for you real quick
so let's do a general with emphasis on
journey
no it's okay if they follow okay ready
yeah
boom ooh i love it
oh and if they say that's fine too now
because we have the rib bones here you
kind of protect yourself from speaking
out or being vocalizing your fear of
being viewed in a different way or
judged to me there's a trauma that you
might have been through
that you kind of protect yourself from
that may be something you need to share
on a bigger level okay an experience
that you either had within yourself or
you might have witnessed or seen in
others okay
that may help you and not saying that
you're gonna profit
but there's definitely something you
have a story to tell and then what's
interesting see the rib bone flipped
see how if it's facing you that's you
protecting yourself i see you protecting
others through your story or through
what you have to share
well that's pretty cool i'm getting
emotional i don't know why i mean i know
why let's pull dylan
let's pull one card
i hope you're not a fraud because i'm
crying
oh
they always pull the death card it's not
physical death i know
are you just saying that no
death is change
death is transition you are on a
transition to a bigger path and as i
said i really see it one where you are
sharing a story or sharing something to
help others oh my gosh wow i you're spot
on
and thank you for that i'm trying to get
myself together because i'm like i'm a
comedian
thank you so much and what i'm going to
do i'm going to give you this malachite
there we go
there we go to help you on your journey
thank you so much oh my gosh that's so
sweet
a lot of people throw the word psychic
around but psychic is an umbrella term
if you look at the root word psychic
it's psyche the ancient greek word for
soul so to me someone who is a psychic
is someone who taps in or can read your
soul it's a personal connection wow i
feel
open raw i feel like oh goodness well
obviously like i guess i want to start
with mystic dylan mystic
which is an iconic name he's
definitely up there you know expert most
likely maybe amateur if mr dylan is not
the expert
i don't know what's going on what is he
doing i don't know what he's doing but
he was doing something iconic eliza she
seemed legit yeah did you feel like you
related to what she was saying um you're
a bit more spiritual a bit more
passionate than you like to let on no
okay now what about natalya she's
definitely passionate about it i feel
like she is
very into it but i don't know how
you know how how many years under her
belt she has i actually personally think
eliza might be
the fraud
really yeah wow
i don't think eliza is a fraud well
maybe we can kind of
manifest it close your eyes for a couple
of seconds
okay
welcome back
come on in
jinx
after much deliberation much
deliberation we
thought that mystic dylan was the expert
the the reason mainly is because he got
me to cry
there was just something really like
genuine so you were able to speak to our
hearts a little bit yeah oh i'm
[Music]
one of the strangest things someone has
asked me when they found out i was
psychic
they immediately pulled me and they're
like great can you help me find my keys
uh and that kind of threw me off and i
was like oh
yes hold on let me tap in
so natalia we thought that you
were the amateur okay we just we felt
like you were super duper knowledgeable
and yeah
kind of like seemingly really really
interested in like becoming an expert
it's me
wow okay hey if they don't think that
i'm the fraud i feel like i did an
accurate job so eliza you were the fraud
do you know anything about how did you
do that you were kind of just off the
dome yes so um
youtube videos about palmistry
um i lied about my nana for this she was
not into kabbalah but she would find
this funny rest in peace
who lies about their grandmother a crazy
jerk i have not worked in reality tv um
i don't feel bad about that and that was
made up oh my gosh 100
non-gmo organic fda certified
you're a different person i'm a
different person after my experience
with mystic dylan
[Music]
matt hit you can't stop thinking about
it really i will say i'm still
kind of on the fence about it wow and i
don't want to sound i don't know it's
okay they did a great job honestly i
actually i think that's healthy being
skeptical i think is healthy and i
gravitate towards people like you
because i'm just like i believe
everything so i'm still doubtful but
maybe y'all have had some experiences
yourselves leave us some comments down
below if you've had any experiences with
psychics i'm sure it wasn't as good as
mine with mystic dylan
did you cry let us know
[Music]
you